Ngày mới chiến tháng chiến tại hà nội, bỏ gần dân với hợp cùng IB Group Việt Nam, chính thức cộng bố sự kiện
ấp nhá khúc tế đặc biệt, sự gây đình là im Việt Nam. Đánh dấu là nấu tiền mô đối
vình thoại sự gây đình biểu dính tại cái đam. Điên nhá sẽ giững xa vào ngày
mời tán tháng nội, năm 2018, tại chúng ta hồi gỡu gốc gia, chúng ta kì
nhậm ba mấy năm sự gây phật của nhóm.
Sĩ Great Garden, là im Việt Nam là sự kiện thứ ba thuộc trôi dự án của tình
Việt Nam, sáng kiến âm nhà quốc tế bị tổn, gió bảo nền dân và IB Group Việt Nam
khởi sướng tự nắp hay nghĩ cuộc trăm thầm em ba. Một tiêu của giữa án là
đưa em nhạc liền cao thế dưới đến cận hơn với khán giả việt. Đồng thời
lăng qua các giá chỉ quan hóa, giành phân và lịch dưới Việt Nam giả thế dưới.
Sáng kiến của mạo rình dân, đề của dưới án của một một bíb dịch Việt Nam.
Lắm bởi lạc kì. Cái sang kìa này là lạc đưa em nhạc liền cao thế dưới đến với người dùng nhả viên
án và cùng mối các nghệ dưới. Vuyện thoại dưới, để cùng chút tay, mạng ra các hóa đúng
đồng đúng Việt Nam. Rồi hai nước lạc chính kế em nhạc và hình ảnh của các nghệ dưới.
Mời là to hả được, nghĩa gái giá chị về phần hoa lịch dưới. Vào đất dưới,
không được Việt Nam mình ra với thế dưới. Chức đó, hai chừng chừng,
kênh gì là im trị Nam, giêm ra vào tháng 9 năm 2018.
Và món là im trị Nam giêm ra vào tháng 9 năm 2019, đá để lại giống bạnh mẽ.
Lặc biệt, dân thung vẻ của các chiên trình, đều được dành để uống hộ.
Chó các chiên trình trịnh quyền và đồng bảo viện rộn bởi gần báo dạc khi năm 2019,
khẳng định tình trịnh quyền xuất của giữa án.
Sịch rõ đình là nhóm nhạc lộn nhạc CPANIST RON LOC LÀN, đến từ nào ý và ngày CBOLIN CHIOLURA SERRY, đến từ ASELAN.
Chúng là đầu tiên đến Việt Nam, Sịch rõ đình sẽ trình giết những các phẩm đã làm nên tên tuổi xuất bắt tập kỳ,
từ các bạn nhạc không lời chứ tình dò hình gành đến dài điều phá trộn giữa cộ nhiệm và dân dân mắc ổ, xanh tích.
Bởi cách dành dựng tình dàng, điểm giếm hế hẹn mang đến trải nhận âm nhà xanh trọng, là tất cả bức tế,
nhưng cũng đầy gần cuối, phù hợp với không phí mổ thu hà nội.
Thì mặt kết hợp, trình dựng dẫn, bởi em vui khoảng bản dưới.
Các nghệ sĩ đến đây hỏi cũng hình hình dựng dựng nguyện nước ngoài, cũng xem hỏi cũng quan tâm những nảm dầu hợp.
Vào chúng tôi tìm tượng rằng nó cũng có một cái phần nhỏ bé trong việc khoảng bà dú lịch.
Đứng nhên là kì vào chúng ta chỉ lớn hơn và cái sĩ chuyển hóa từ gật xem những người dung này đến kế hành động.
Đến Việt Nam đi dù lịch và trải nhở, và chỉ tiêu cái Việt Nam thì chúng ta cũng khó lòng đòi nữa.
Chắc sẵn là cần phải làm nhiều hơn nữa.
Để tiếp tục đọng ngóch vào vừa phát triển, và có mọi rối lịch cũng nảy theo kết thân này.
Secureate Garden là In Việt Nam sẽ dân ra vào lúc mùi chính giở vào mì phút ngày mời tạm tháng 12, năm 2018,
tại chúng ta vô gỡ cúc ra mì định hà nội.
Để không chỉ là món quả tinh thần mà bá tổ chức mỗi người tạng khán giải yung nhạc.
Mà còn là sự kiện tiếp nối tinh thần áp nhạc đi cộng đồng.
Khi mỗi tình vẽ đều mang giá trị nhân văn gói phần vào các khoảng độc thiệt đội.
Cùng với thành công của hát triển, Kheny G là In Việt Nam, dân ra vào tháng 12,
hôm trong thời gian và món lại In Việt Nam, dân ra vào tháng 12, năm 2018,
truyết sự kiện này đã mình chứng cho sức mạnh của ông nhà trong việc khoảng bá hình gạnh Việt Nam ra thế giới.
Những giai điều ở vừa thời gian của SIC-REEDH HADEN, khi mang lên giữa lọc hà nội, sẽ mang đến một trải nghiệm nghệ thuật lần,
tất uống kế, đồng thời khảnh định nấu lực, đưa tinh qua ông nhà thế giới đến tất hơn với công chứng tại Việt Nam.